il ya deux jours j'étais au fameux
festival d'avignon où j'ai organisé un
atelier de discussions de débats autour
de achetés avec des bâtons de mieux
c'était l'occasion de faire un bilan sur
l'année qui vient de s'écouler et
d'essayer de réfléchir à ce qu'ils
pouvaient ou là où ça devait s'en aller
pour notamment l'année à venir et pour
les années à venir
et c'était vraiment fascinante très
intéressant et sans plus tarder
d'ailleurs je vais vous passez
simplement l'enregistrement de ceux de
cet atelier
avec
bonjour à tous donc qui ne me connaît
pas c'est pas grave
des amis qui connaissent donc j'appelle
les achemine cinq forums vidéaste et je
m'intéresse beaucoup à pas mal de crâne
de société et je pense qu'un des gros
problème aujourd'hui c'est la qualité
des débats que l'on a donc si fine
équipe i koné twitter normalement si
vous avez déjà vu twitter vous savez que
les débats s'est pas toujours aussi bien
que ce qu'on aimerait que ce soit et du
coup je pense qu'il manque aussi de
réflexion sur comment mieux débattre
façon générale on a souvent des
intuitions mais ça vaut le coup de mieux
et réfléchir réponse est en tout cas moi
c'était un nom surtout que je me mets
dessus ainsi de réfléchir à ça et j'ai
lancé un hashtag du high art au nom qui
s'appelle hashtag des bâtons mieux et en
fait c'était quasiment pile il ya un an
donc j'aimerais commencer parce que tu
es un joyeux anniversaire à intégrer ton
mieux joyeux anniversaire joyeux
[Musique]
anniversaire jozami mercer attaquera ton
meilleur niveau peuple voilà c'est tout
audio univers alors donc ça fait un an
que j'ai lancé le hashtag et voilà c'est
le temps de faire un peu un bilan va
dire globalement je pense que c'est il
ya beaucoup d'aspects qui nous pensons
ainsi positif je pense que des aspects
qui sont assez négatif malheureusement
notamment par exemple plus fait que
hashtag des bâtons mieux est
malheureusement souvent utilisé au
moment d'un débat où ça se passe mal et
on dira l'autre hashtag des bateaux
mieux en disant à l'autre tu fais de la
merde quoi
et c'est pas cool de l'elysée comme ça
c'est un des travers du coup c'est de
réfléchir à tout ça et du coup plutôt
que ces dames de dire aux gens
achetaient des bâtons mieux je pense que
c'est utile d'avoir une réflexion sur
comment mieux débattre
donc c'est pour ça que le type de 7 cet
atelier c'est des bâtons mieux de débat
tombe finalement donc ça c'est un truc
que j'ai déjà fait plusieurs fois
annoncée en fait j'avais fait ça
plusieurs événements où j'essaie
d'organiser des débats sur comment mieux
débattre et globalement ça va ça c'est
ce qu'avance et quand même lorsqu'on
débat de comment bien débattre c'est pas
toujours l'idéal il ya parfois des trucs
qui sont bâillon à dire et ça c'est
peut-être parce que je m'y prends mal
enfin je l'organisé débat sur des bâtons
et peut-être que je débat mal de comment
mieux débattre avec ces parts étaient
très clairement et du coup si on veut
s'améliorer à sa débattre mieux de
lettres de mieux débattre de mieux
débattre
donc là on est un truc ultra métal s'est
achevée avec des bâtons mieux de hashtag
des bateaux en direct avec des matériaux
en particulier pas question que
j'aimerais vous poser c'est qu'elles
sont les débats qu'il faudra avoir sur
comment mieux débattre
quelles sont les questions qu'on se pose
pas assez parce qu'on invite les gens à
mieux débattre à ccc le thème c du tram
été relâchés désolé qu'elle adore ça et
du coup j'ai beaucoup vous laisser la
parole
l'idée en particulier l'impact de cette
cet atelier normalement c'est de choisir
mes prochaines vidéos sur des bâtons
bien parce que c'est de ça dont on parle
je veux savoir qu'est ce qu'elles sont
et sujet que je devrais abordés lorsque
le prince a mieux débattre
oui oui
ok du coup oui alors je pense que la
plupart des joueurs après la question
c'est comment on amène les gens quand on
débat de soirée quelle est la manière
dont quelle est la question qu'on doit
se poser sur est ce que c'est un sujet
qu'il faudra aborder par exemple dans
les vidéos où dans le monde et fred sur
comment mieux débattre et comment est-ce
qu'on l'amène jeu du suisse il ya des
gens qui meurent à louis qu'est ce qui
fait qu est ce qui fait un bon débat
donc du coup on a piqué pénètre pas
assez à qu'est ce qui fait un bon débat
ce que j'avais envie de dire ce que moi
j'ai du mal à admettre que je dis pas ce
que je dis pas mal ouais en fait c'est
ce que vient de faire mais bon c'est en
fait c'est quand on se pose des
questions si c'est aussi devoir qu'ont
fait les autres batman mais c'est très
difficile de voir toutefois soi même on
est pas mal parce qu'ils sont des bas de
la façon dont on débat c'est qu'on a
l'impression qu'on ne fait pas de la
bonne façon
d'une certaine manière non débattrait
pas comme ça du coup quand on essaie de
poser la question aux autres essayer de
trouver ou pourquoi vous débattez mal
ces personnels ont précision pas
réfléchi elles ont du mal à répondre
parce que si elle débattent de la façon
dont elle prépare ses considère qu'être
débattent bien d'un point de vue donc du
coup faudrait trouver un moyen de faire
montrer aux gens m'aiment bien
évidemment que quand on débat ya
forcément des choses qui vont pas un
outil qui a été montré par pas que ça
fait le chat sceptiques qui a fait lui
si blanc fait avec différents arguments
si on est aux couleurs de la cie
pourquoi ce débat bien et à l'extérieur
c'est plus que ça peut être un outil qui
est un peu ludique pour essayer de
recentrer sur lieux d'émeutes
ok peut-être l'application personnes
personnels à définir parce qu'en fait
forcément quand on va débattre ans ma
venue d'une certaine manière parce que
justement si en fait on n'a pas des
arguments se trouve avoir à perdre entre
guillemets un débat sienne il est sûr de
gagner
erdre forcément se sent impliqué
personnellement en fait attaqué enfin
elle souvent une idée deux ans mais sa
personne en jeu en fait ce qu'on est en
fait voilà en fonction de débat qui est
public il ya en face ça va changer
la posture de la personne qui les vend
de plus ou moins d'espoir s'engager dans
un débat avoir raison parce que les gens
qui le regardent alors généralement en
cours elles exigent typiquement à
débattre quand tu joues un débat sur
twitter si vous voulez vraiment la voie
a pu la voir en privé
en fait ça se passera sans beaucoup de
moyens que pour faire des bonds des
dates déjà posé des bons débat parce que
le problème vient pas forcément les
débatteurs ça sachez que ça est
extrêmement mal posée par an et des
cartésiens
c'est oui ou non alors que la réalité
c'est que la plupart des situations des
thèmes sont très nuancée et que le fait
de poser des 26 cartésien empêche la
douce à la bienveillance l'argumentation
et ça entraîne forcément l'opposition et
je pense qu'avant de parler de débatteur
il faut d'abord savoir poser un débat et
arrêter de sortir enfin sortir du binôme
du pur contre les saints de faire sens
que tu vie parce que l'encontre des fois
des débats typiquement différents
publics je sais pas moi l'été à la télé
l'objectif c'est absolument pas de
convaincre l'autre du débat c'est de
convaincre le public
donc là c'est un objectif étant alors
que quand c'est plus en privé vraiment
que avec ses proches
là c'est plus pour nous pour chercher un
peu à part des choses entre celui ci on
cherche vraiment avancer sur les idées
c'est d'abord d'arriver à ce mets à la
place de la personne fasse ça revient à
se dire pourquoi est ce qu'on débat mais
ce qu'on débat juste pourquoi que la
personne le gérer son amante à tort et
puis c'est tout ou est-ce qu'on débat
histoire de dire je vous posais d'un
point de vue à la personne en face et
peut-être qu à la fin on se sera pas
mise d'accord mais ça aurait fait
avancer aussi des points de vue sur la
question
voilà donc juste pour vous la péter un
petit peu la première vidéo de série à
mieux c'était sûr pourquoi ce sont des
vérités
c'est pour marquer un point parce que ça
me rappelle quelque chose
après j'avais regardé un lieu un oeil ou
tueurs carnesi des débats bah je sais
pas quoi dire tiens en train d'aimer
dinan une table-ronde mais il ya des
gens que vous aviez tout en lançant une
table ronde il faut il s'en va il
voulait pas dire débat parce que pour
les débats c'est un truc violents
combats je pense que vous voulez
débattre de de l'appellation des bâtons
qui est un débat que j'ai pas
suffisamment eu justement savons que ça
intéresse
une table ronde sur dont 15 h table
ronde soit rétabli finalement d'aucun du
passé quand même un truc sur lequel j'ai
un peu réfléchi surtout moi on va pas
mal fait réfléchir en gros il ya
plusieurs appellations possible
différentes de débats ou même de débat
tant mieux l'une des propositions noir
tables rondes seront jamais entendu donc
c'est intéressant c'est cool c'est un
truc que vous entendez vous ces échanges
bienveillant la place de bâton de vos
conversations tout court version et
sinon moi ce que j'essaie de faire en
fait c'est à chaque fois que le débat
tout mais c'est de suivre sa part
réfléchir collectivement c'est un peu ce
que j'essaie de faire la raison pour
laquelle je suis resté sur des bâtons
mieux c'est que mon billet des couilles
irrécupérable mais aussi en fait le
problème c'est que si elle pointe de la
transférabilité jeu parce qu'ils ont
parlé avec christophe et jean mentale
seulement il en parle un peu de temps
plus c'est le fameux c'est qu'on apprend
des choses des biais cognitifs comme moi
on les apprend dans un domaine et on les
applique pas dans d'autres domaines
donc je pense que c'est très intéressant
d'avoir une discussion sur des échanges
bienveillant qu'est ce qu'un échange
intéressant tout ça
le truc que je crains c'est c'est qu'on
transfère pas ça au débat sérieux ou des
bars important c'est pour ça que je
pense que c'est un pas important travail
sur la transférabilité 60 général est
pour ça que je trouve ça inutile en fait
d'utiliser des bâtons mieux parce que
c'est lorsqu'on se met à débattre c'est
quand même pas débattre qu'il faut
penser à débattement
c'est un petit con un argumentaire en
quoi est-ce qu'il est fallacieux
contredisez mois et y ait un échange
bienveillant une réflexion collective
sur cette question ce qui inquiète de
voir ça il ya des personnes qui aiment
pas débattre parce qu'elles se sentent
attaqués à partir du moment où la
personne en face à mon avis contraire
même si différent même si les choses de
façon bienveillante ça se retrouve
souvent dans des conversations sur
facebook c'est mon péché mignon débats
furent fils n'est pas un péché mignon
plombe du tout et du coup on fait
rapidement les gens désolé parce que ça
part en débat on s'excuse parce que ça
devient une conversation on échange des
points donc il ya déjà ce clivage la
même pas débattre
donc ça bascule facilement dans le
règlement qui parlera pas du tout même
si on a ajouté à ça il ya aussi le
problème de il faut faire quelque chose
et demi fond de violence ne pas imaginer
que l'autre en fait un autre point de
vue secret de hanna d'un nom de penser
qu en été quand il veut dire autre chose
vous allez c'est autre chose alors je
vais faire un peu le mec égocentrique
apparaître je suis au centre du cercle
mais ce qui m'intéresse pas être pas mal
moi c'est vraiment un truc que je suis
un peu fait mes vidéos je vais sortir
des vidéos sur le sujet et j'aimerais
qu'elle soit bonne donc j'aimerais que
vous m'aidiez dit que tout ce que je
suis mal donc d'y revenir sur la
question la terminologie
c'est ce que ces avis sur la
terminologie hashtag et bâtons vieux
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bien ce
qu'on sait que c'est mal à l'aise pour
remplacer ça qu'elle devrait être ma
stratégie finalement pourra amener les
gens à mieux débattre
je suis désolé d'être aussi égocentrique
conseille vraiment concret comme donner
une heuristique de débats qui servirait
un peu un objet des gens qui débattent
on commence le débat toujours un début
de débat donné l'objectif du débat mais
là ça vous y rendre des règles à suivre
quand on est conscient qu'on est en
transit bamba donc je devrais faire des
vidéos qu'ils fassent d'une part de sa
septième faudrait pas vérifié son ide
quel état d'esprit on est aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on n'est pas un petit peu
énervé parce que j'avais envie de débats
quénéhervé je ne sais même pas la grande
cinq minutes pour savoir si mon état
on est donc peut-être vidéo à venir
pardon ce nouveau part de l'état et puis
celui des gens trop si c'est une
remarque confession tout à l'heure en
10e on pense tout ce qu'on débat bien
moi je trouve intéressant c'est déjà pas
mal de réactions à ta vidéo on veut tout
ou à la cible de leur âme aux sceptiques
qui sont ouais je suis d'accord dans la
théorie mais dans la pratique quand tu
te bats avec un homéopathe ya un moment
tu pète un câble parce que j'y viens il
ya beaucoup de gens sceptiques et ou qui
disent ouais ok je suis d'accord la
théorie mais dans la pratique ça ne
saoule je suis incapable et qui
admettent leur défaite
enfin qui sont en cours ils
reconnaissent un peu qu'ils sont
faillibles sur ce côté là qui paie pas
d'amiante mais qui accepte le fait qu'
ils sont pas failli parce que s'ils
choisissent comme ça c'est que dimanche
ils se disent ça vaut pas le coup
quelques pas et donc ça c'est pas une
réponse à ta question mais c'est
peut-être ce côté là comment amener ces
gens à dire c'est rentable de faire
l'effort une question que je me pose
énormément
si vous avez des idées je suis la paix
mais peut-être tout simplement tu as un
sujet qui est pas du tout trop polémique
et tu montre un exemple peut-être
simplement et peut-être même après
expliquer pourquoi t'as fait ça et
peut-être comme ça les gens y voit le
résultat d'une profession sur ce que je
devrais faire
sur la terminologie arrêt sur le débat
tout mieux je pense que c'est nécessaire
son mode débattre parce que c'est ce que
les gens ont dans l'imaginaire collectif
c'est le débat mais après vie c'est le
mode ne faut pas oublier que mot
débattre est assez violent en soi et que
c'est toujours une violence que ce soit
en termes d'éducation de d'apporter des
choses nouvelles à quelqu'un donc lui
faire changer son point de vue qui était
ancré dessus donc il était comme pas que
c'était çà çà çà bases solides et
combien lui taper dessus pour dire
attention c'est pas si solide que ça sur
quoi tu étais c'est toujours une
violence dont puis il ya cette violence
dans le débat qui est inhérente au fait
de devoir essayer de faire changer
d'avis ou même de montrer que ce qu'on
pensait n'est pas tout à fait juste et
que après il faut aussi toulon prendre
le contexte dans lequel ces les a priori
des personnes dont l'hygiène mentale a
fait une très bonne conférence peu plus
tôt dans la journée sur sa où il faut
bien penser à où est ce que la personne
en est et que si elle est très très loin
d'un sujet dont on parle est convaincu
que terre est plate que pour lui faire
la bascule bas il va falloir donc vous
prouver par groupe ou d'arguments et qu'
il faut ne pas oublier d'où elle part
donc accessible si je récapitule je
garde et des batignolles et et peut-être
des vidéos sur réfléchir à ce que
l'autre pense et lorsqu'il y avait une
émission de juger quelle est justement
sur le processus de comment les gens qui
a détrôné et du coup elle avait quitté
leur était quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
bossé sur le processus qui fait que les
personnes changent day qui disaient que
c'est extrêmement difficile à cerner et
qu'une des pistes ce serait de bain de
poser des questions à la personne sur
prendre l'opinion la personne derrière
mais pourquoi tu portes ça et
déconstruire un peu comment il en est
venu à penser ça c'est peut être un des
moyens comprendre la position de l'autre
en l'interrogeant sa position pourquoi
tu crois ce que tu crois parce que s'il
est vraiment convaincu comme pour la
terre plate
tu sais très bien que quand tu va
discuter lui va pas changer d'avis comme
ça mais tu peux au moins et s'ils lui
faire faire partie du chemin en faisant
se questionner sur ses propres croyances
je crois qu'il ya monsieur sam raimi qui
tous les mois me demande une vidéo sur
les entretiens fiscalité que ça va venir
servir
il est peut-être un autre truc c'est de
savoir quand est-ce qu'il faut savoir
abandonner
non mais non c'est important pour à dire
tellement parce que prendre se sent mal
parce que ça marche pas alors que les
situations simplement ça rejoint l'état
de débauche je suis rigide mental de
crise et paris deux mois bien le jour
j'ai compris qu'on n'avait pas tous
leurs priorités pas très touché c'est
vraiment un truc que j'ai compris qui
fait que je m'énerve - quand je débats
auxquels il y aura des vidéos sur les
entretiens épistémique est sûr réfléchir
à ce que l'autre pense à dire oui juste
par rapport à ce que j'ai entendu sur la
paire plate en fait son art vient se
déposer aussi des débats cohérent parce
qu'il ya des sujets qui sont des sujets
à débat donc c'est des débats d'idées de
ça va être des débats philosophiques de
positionnement politique etc
par contre il ya des choses qui ne
prennent pas un débat qui sont des
vérités scientifiques par exemple moi si
tu devais passer un débat pour savoir si
le soleil existe parce que ça ça énerve
par contre vraiment moi je vais pas
débattre c'est un débat d'idées là on
est en train de passer d'une vérité
scientifique la terre n'est pas plate le
soleil existe ça c'est pas de débat posé
prête pas parce que c'est comme si on
disait à ces gens là que le leur idée
est valable et là ce n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas la réalité donc on en
revient là il faut vraiment posé des
débats aussi cohérent faux faux faux
débat d'idées qu'on va pas deux as de la
science qui a été prouvé depuis treize
ans et pas par un débat à partir moi on
ouvre le débat
on se met à débattre d'un truc je sais
pas je vais pas débattre du soleil le
soleil il existe donc là on va leur
prouver que le soleil existe donc ça
doit être une démarche scientifique
n'aurait pas de remettre en cause le
soleil quoi s'est passé jeudi il faut
poser des bombes et le problème
je trouve qu'on ne débatte vraiment
parfois de choses qui ne méritent pas
déballé qui sont dangereuses il savait
déjà arrivé plusieurs reprises de le
comprendre de ce côté à moi j'ai pris
cet exemple là parce que c'était pareil
on peut se demander c'est vraiment
intéressant de pause estivale à mes
soucis c'est qu'il peut aussi après se
poser la question de nos a priori nous
parce que je pense que la plupart en se
dilater rires montent pas il estime
qu'on est un peu écrasée sur l'épaule et
que donc on a cet a priori la compense
vrai qu'on est convaincu que c'est vrai
parce qu'on a la science etc etc mais à
prester des gens qui vont pas que la
terre est plate ont aussi leurs raisons
plus ou moins valables mais qui pour eux
sont très valables et donc je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à nos propres
à priori à nos propres convictions qui
peuvent venir entraver parfois et porter
un jugement dont qui est un peu qui
n'est pas bienveillant pour le coup que
leurs idées à eux n'est pas bonne
lorsque donc là la banque terme ans il
ya un débat assurée ce qu'un truc est un
débat est ce que ce débat est un débat
ce doit être du renseignement doit
partir de cohérent et la voilà la
peinture nathan couleurs un magicien là
dessus par contre il ya des choses sont
des vérités sans suite ne doit pas être
sujette à débat c'est pas un gros
problème
enfin près bon plein de remettre en
question le fait que l'internet un
plateau pas être en dedans j'ai jugé
donner mon avis sur ça et j'aimerais
qu'on passe un peu gros non pas
évidemment me donne envie après donc
chez moi il ya des sujets scientifiques
sur lesquelles ya des consensus très
marquée en portant de temps prendre note
après au sein d'un comité scientifique
ya beaucoup de débats sur l'état des
connaissances en sciences
par exemple sur oise aghlabides à nice
mme le lait des débats il ya tous les
domaines il ya plein plein de questions
qui sont débattues entre entre
scientifiques
oui oui oui oui
et sinon je vais encore faire
l'égocentrique et je pense que j'ai
beaucoup le faire quelles sont les
prochaines vidéos qu'elles sont un sujet
que quelqu'un qui veut faire des vidéos
sur chaque bateau n'est pas forcément
moi mais bon moi devrait quels sont les
sujets que vous devrez abordés et qui
n'ont pas été suffisants crette par
exemple oui est ce que nos débats face à
un questionnement sur le format en fait
par exemple on avait beaucoup de formats
pour les gens qui se sert pour débattre
par exemple twitter parce que justement
le fait pour ça que des textes courts ça
peut amener des problèmes de contraintes
même les débats télévisés qui sont
relativement courts en fait c'était
difficile de développer clairement à
nanterre
je te manque de l'autre questionné en
fait les ensembles exprimez vous trouvez
en fait peut-être quelque chose
d'optimal en fait pour ça et bien mis en
débat merci bonsoir vidéo soit titre de
ma vidéo sur la forme adoptée pour un
débat technique qui sont utilisés par
les associations pour faire des débats
les débats d'idées sans tousser au
dessus et en même temps et c'est
vraiment au lieu de dire non je suis pas
d'accord tu étais qu un pauvre nul à ce
que tu penses sénas j'utilise des gestes
je pense qu'il ya peut-être d'autres
techniques qui n'atteignent plein jeu
négociable ça pourrait être une façon de
savoir comment utiliser cette rue de la
banque à la barre à ce sujet donc il ya
une vidéo que fait non il ya un article
qui traînent sur mon ordinateur depuis
presque un an et que je sens et les lire
et qui quitte donc c'est mehdi moussaïd
le sco pis pour ceux qui connaissent qui
en a qui m'en avait parlé
donc il ya des études qui ont fait voilà
on a fait des différents groupes qui
devaient résoudre une tâche est ce que
ce qui est chercheur a observé c'est que
les groupes qui étaient très bons pour
résoudre cette tâche s'était pas ceux
qui avaient un grand cuit c'était ce qui
avait notamment une capacité
donc il mesurait la capacité des
différentes personnes à détecter les
émotions pendant qu'au moment où on
entend juste le haut d'une photo où le
bas d'une photo de winne et l'émotion de
la personne et 6 à observer c'est que
les groupes il y avait beaucoup de gens
comme ça et les meilleurs ils à leurs
tâches et ça se traduisait aussi dans le
débat
quoi par une meilleure répartition du
temps de parole typiquement donc pas
juste équilibré mais également plus de
temps de parole à des gens qui
comprennent mieux le suivais ça c'est un
truc que je dois faire un fn ça fait un
an que je dois le faire et elle va le
perdre
alors en fait moi c'est un petit peu une
sorte de critique de débats tant mieux
je suis à toi c'est clairement sur
twitter la plupart des gens de la
communauté de la vulgarisation ils sont
plutôt hashtag débattront bien mais pas
tous au même niveau il se met certaines
limites au bout d'un moment ils sont
plus ou moins hashtag des bâtons mieux
et au bout d'un moment dans certaines
discussions ils se disent voilà on à
sortir ce moment là je tacle bâton mieux
ça marche qu'il faut passer à autre
chose
alors du coup mon avis ya peut-être un
petit peu de frais dans ses critiques là
et une vidéo limite du hashtag des
bâtons mieux où les critiques du hashtag
des voix tant mieux on va peut-être être
intéressante donc évidement du coup
quelqu'un veut critiquer des bâtons ou
en fin de compte ça serait peut-être une
idée de continuer pourquoi on ne sait
pas si ça marcherait pour tous les
débats mais pourquoi au début de chaque
débat ne pas donner une sorte de scène
de probabilités enfin de certitudes
quant à notre opinion c'est je sais pas
si vous connaissez la chaîne mr sam
c'est lui qui me fait chier avec une
entretien épistémique lieu en période
les jeunes je trouve qu'il a d'assez
bons réflexes de débats et notamment
avec une espèce de curseur sur ses
propres opinions
et suite à ça on pourrait même annoncer
de soi même qu'est-ce qu'ils pourraient
nous faire changer d'avis quand on notre
opinion donc il ya un autre principe
aussi s'appelle le point d'une nuit ou
du double ne le nom du débat
c'est typiquement le point un point
c'est peu si possible sur lequel on
n'est pas d'accord ici on arrivait à
être d'accord sur ce point vous serez
d'accord sur tout il idéalement c'est
vraiment un double ne sait d'ailleurs
que on voit un cette visite il faut
également c'est un fake donné à regarder
en garde à donner et puis on sait que on
sera d'accord après avoir vu la donner
ça semble idéal l'idée plus globale
c'est vraiment un c'est d'identifier le
point le point ou s'ils ont des mails s
ne soutient et oui il y aura des vidéos
sur ça mais beaucoup trop de lui doit le
faire oui la source
après un débat donc à l'école ouais je
sais que je suis en vie en milieu
scolaire ont par exemple les cours
d'histoire-géographie et d'éducation
morale et civique
ils organisent n'était pas voir quelles
méthodes les enseignants mettent en
place donc c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
bâton de parole qui se fait et c est
voir si ça peut avoir des influences
après sur la représentation du départ
quand des adolescents qui ensuite
viendront ceux qui dépasseront plus tard
enfin c'est à d'après scolaire cherchait
un peu critique des approches colère
parce que ça touche que les enfants
enfin les gens qui sont à l'école cc
c'est très important et tout mais enfin
la plupart des gens sont déjà sur
twitter une vidéo là dessus mais aussi
tout l'approchent communication étape
avec toutes mes vidéos plateforme iad
approche communication en fait là
comment dire l'interprétation des gens
surtout quand on est à l'oral ou à
l'écrit ça change énormément les mots
qu'on emploie souvent faim quand on est
à l'écrit je me sens très là dessus on a
un style d'écriture on a parfois des
travers d'écriture donc la façon dont la
personne reçoit l'argument il ya déjà un
billet à ce moment là c'est à partir du
moment où on est à l'écrit donc ça peut
être l'ensemble de la communication ça
peut être intéressant
comment ça fonctionne en fait la donne
ça c'est si une ville aussi que
j'aimerais c'est getafe région notamment
en fait le fait que l' on écrit un débat
une espère qu'il sera reçue d'une
certaine manière mais faut pas juste
compter sur ce qu'on espère enfin faut
essayer d'anticiper quels seront les
réceptions probable des thèmes tels
messages bien sûr cela veut dire que ce
soit un truc sur l'a10 vers mad que je
me suis rendu compte que plusieurs fois
que j'ai discuté avec des genres
j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait une
puissance super extra et en fait c'est
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas du tout les
mêmes défis sont mois et le trucage ou
appel à un moment où moi je pensais que
notre terrasse et c'est l'autre pensait
que moi j'étais raciste
donc c'est de clarifier ça revient aussi
souvent prennent de trouver le noeud du
débat fait ça saoule n'y a pas de note
et c'est de réfléchir une eau du débat
il ya un autre point aussi que je
voulais dire c'est une idée qui m'a été
suggéré sur twitter et je trouvais ça
intéressant c'est aussi de mettre plus
démoli dans les tweets sur tout le monde
eut débattant des senoussis bienveillant
qui parce que on reçoit souvent la
réception est souvent plus dur que ce
qu'on imagine des critiques de but de
tes vidéos c'est de faire mieux des
vainqueurs jean une fois que tu as
identifié plusieurs objectifs
instrumentaux l'empathie la violence
tout ça je peux faire des vidéos qui est
les gens à travailler la bienveillance
sur papier
je pense que c'est un point important
dans les faits donc j'ai déjà fait une
vidéo notamment ou le parle d'un texan
livre qui s'appelle sont plus le titre
feeling good ou c'est un psychiatre qui
passe un petit 4 et travaille beaucoup
sur les émotions du coût de ses passions
il réfléchit aussi beaucoup à comment
améliorer les émotions juste avec des
travaux cognitif sur sur nous-mêmes que
je cherchais à être bienveillant fait ça
aide d'être bienveillant dessus c'était
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de chance tout cas
sur ma chaîne qui va me voir des gens
qui sont pas extrémistes où vous voyez
en fait ils se foutent complètement
2 parce qu'ils veulent même plus aller
dans un quelconque débat avec eux farce
et oui oui oui tu as raison
oui oui ça lui oui bien sûr lui est en
fait il me pose souvent la question mais
comment je rattrape une parce que ça me
seulement merde parce que quelque part
du coup ça l'enfer mais aussi enfin ça
n'améliore rien et donc comment
réamorcer en espèce de débat avec
quelqu'un qu'à virer voilà après un peu
sectaire pour sur telle ou telle clé etc
ça va peut-être que tu es déjà traités
non mais c'est vrai que
je suis désespéré ne pas avoir la
réponse en fait j'ai beau leur dire
nécessaire un bruit j'allais donc
comment amorcer un débat et away non
c'est oui c'est vraiment ça encore
comment comment essayer de ramener des
fois après la raison mais peut-être en
tout cas de débattre avec quelqu'un qui
est vraiment fermé peut-être que ça
vient peut-être ou c'est impossible
j'en sais rien mais il y en a je sais
que moi des gens qui sont assez
complètes possibles
il ne bougeait pas de vidéo à faire
c'est sûr on pense qu'il n'y a pas de
vidéo entièrement mais ces voix là parce
que moi même j'ai été pas envie de
débattre avec givet pas parce que tu es
là tu vois tu vois je peux tu vas passer
deux jours tiens problème la personne en
question
le mieux c'est de la diriger vers des
associations comme la miviludes dans
toute chose pour y chercher conseils
justement pas pour balancer dinan talent
personnel extremism terrain mais pour
dire comment je fais pour mieux discuter
cette personne là et bien souvent la
meilleure des façons puisque j'ai appris
le sud c'est de pas contredire la
personne parce que le fait de la
contredire
dans la secte ou dans le vent extémistes
qu'elle aura en face d'elle en lui aura
dit vous allez voir les gens dans
entourage n'ont pas de comprendre il n'y
a que chez nous quand on comprend donc
en fait ça fait une espèce de prophétie
auto réalisatrice
donc le mieux ses 17 des rêves c'est de
rester plus bienveillants possible et de
le questionner et avec le questionner
jusqu'à ce qu'ils voient qu'un truc qui
cloche c'est vrai que pour le coup
débattre dans ce cas de figure
en fait moi ça n'arrête une question
parce que je vois beaucoup il est par
exemple définir en un niveau de mentir
de certitudes par exemple et est ce que
en fait ça pourrait être quelque chose
de positif dans un débat justement de
minimiser ses points de vue en fait
c'est plus une question là à ce moment
qu'est ce que ça peut apporter en fait
dans un débat ne fait vraiment pas que
personne n'a cessé d'être points de vie
que juste en traitent le sujet et est-ce
que ça près pour peut être pas de créer
un sur deux cadres bienveillant dans le
sens où justement il n'y a pas de
conflit c'est juste une question de
réfléchir ce sujet pour peut-être à la
fin après et développer son point de vue
là je pense aussi par voir ça il ya un
vrai travail à faire pendant et avant le
débat d'extériorisation entre la
personne qui fait le bal les personnes
et leurs avis et de se dire j'ai mon
avis mais on m'attaque pas moi et je
pense qu'il faudrait traiter de cette
technique de noël puis distancer du tout
l'avis de son éruption de son niveau la
dirno on est fait faute à des vidéos sur
sa merci aussi dans ce débat il ya un
moyen qui sait communication non
violente et qui permet en fait de
déterminer les intentions et surtout les
besoins de la personne en face et ça en
fait ça permet du coup de pouvoir
traiter avec la personne et en répétant
fait ce qu'elle nous dit et en essayant
de comprendre ce qu est le tir derrière
et ça permet dé d'accord avec elle sur
c'est sur ces arguments et au final de
moins avoir de problèmes de
communication avec l'autre et de pauvres
nous pouvoir avancer en fait sur des
problèmes et c'est un psychiatre qui a
fait ça et il avait les théories des
gens qui était totalement contre oubliez
à la basse et justes en répétant ce que
eux lui disait et en affectant son point
de vue et en étant d'accord au fur et à
mesure à la fin j'ai vraiment bien son
temps d avoir un débat cohérent
rappellera que sur ce que tu as dis donc
des idées que j'ai pour des prochaines
vidéos penser si la merde
c'est qu'ils avaient entendu mois + moi
puissent plus moi plus et moi plus plus
sa présence a donc
donc il ya un peu cette idée dans
certaines de mes vidéos pas beaucoup
mais j'aimerais mettre plus en avant ses
s'éveiller que yann moix mois qu'il a et
c'est pas la meilleure version de moi
parce que je suis fatigué j'ai fait et
voilà
et il ya les meilleures versions des
mois qui sera plus cohérent plus bien
démonter tout ça donc ça serait ce qu on
appelle un mois + corps il ya mieux
réfléchi et que ça
donc moi puisque c'est une mois idéal
qui peut plus améliorée l'idée a du coup
ça serait temps de faire un mois puisse
plus donc je pense que l'idée du mois +
permet un peu de se distancer sévir
contre n'est pas on n'est pas celui
qu'on veut être peut-être c'est
peut-être moins de ma très beau un peu
plus loin et a pris un autre concept
aussi j'ai dit qu'une fois donc on
n'avait pas entendu c'est le concept de
moi moi certes la plupart du temps en
fait je suis en moi - c'est que je suis
moins bien que ce que moi en temps
normal typiquement parce que j'ai faim
parce que quelqu'un m'énerve et du coup
je pense que ça peut être utile d'être
sensible à ces différentes versions du
mois ok alors fait passer à comme tu
veux j'ai un autre projet avec des
bâtons mieux aujourd'hui c'est l'image
de débats tant mieux je sais pas si vous
le savez mais sur twitter il ya plus de
gens qui critiquent ouvertement bateau
mieux et il fallait des critiques qui
sont des critiques très intéressante il
ya des critiques qui sont liées au fait
que hashtag bâtons utilisés pendant les
débats du coup c'est un peu moralisateur
et puis à des gens qui sont globalement
j'en suis plus en plus considéré comme
quelqu'un de moralisateurs qui fait
chier tout le monde qui ramène sa morale
globalement la morale se passe quelque
chose de très bon vu et ça ça me semble
être un vrai problème
du coup mon gros problème en ce moment
surtout c'est comment qu'est ce que je
fais par rapport à son comment comment
est ce que je peux non plus être
moralisateur tout en encourageant les
gens à mieux débattre et j'ai
l'impression que c'est la vidéo twitter
c'est d'abandonner d'avoir de l'argent
qui tombe dessus donc parce que je sais
pas mais moi je sais pas combien de gens
de critiques là dessus mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est peut-être souvent
mal ce qui parle tu sais on a
l'impression que du coup ça représente
beaucoup de gens etc
jusqu'à combien étape tranquille sur sa
chaîne je crois un certain nombre à ce
qu'il présente vraiment personne qui
disait on m'a posé on sait par personne
en fait j'ai pas donner de noms mais il
ya quand même des gens assez influent
dans la sphère sceptiques notamment ou
scientifiques qui m'ont critiqué en
public ou en privé sur l'utilisation de
l'excès de côté moralisateur de débattre
parce qu'ils se sont touchés dans leur
phase il débattre reste un pagne pour ma
peau se trouvent les places je pense que
toutes les personnes qui ont une volonté
pédagogique leur encontre à un moment ou
un autre parce que vous aura toujours
quelqu'un façon pas donner à boire un
âne qui n'a pas soif en fait donc on
aura toujours cette posture laddh
c'est pas une posture d'autorité mais
quand on veut transférer un savoir il y
aura toujours quelqu'un qui bat si vous
posez donc c'est que la vente massive
mais pour tous les gars que je pense que
je suis en tort ces jeunes oui il des
débats sur sur ça
ben je pense personnellement que des
bâtons mieux c'est quelque chose de très
important aujourd'hui que la potentielle
une collaboration mise en avant de
toutes sortes d'idées complexe et passe
par une réflexion collective
du coup il faut débattre et il faut
qu'il faut en tout cas et changer voire
d'infection collective et c'est super
important de bien le faire du coup je
pense qu'il ya vraiment un enjeu énorme
ils essaient d'attirer les gens sur cet
objectif mais mais je suis encore ce
problème et il est peut-être un truc
tout bête c'est que au lieu de dire j'ai
envie nuggets hier je vous arrête du
processus il faut ne pas dire vous
faites mal voilà comment tire bien vous
dire vous et non une situation et moi
c'est dans un conseiller pour avoir une
meilleure vie voilà c'est clairement un
des trucs que je pense essayer ferme les
critiques c'est pas tant le côté mode
validateurs que aussi idéaliste il ya
des gens qui trouvent que justement le
côté débat tant mieux c'est c'était trop
idéaliste qui disent que t'es trouve
côté mathématique mais c'est vrai que
dans beaucoup de débats par rapport à
beaucoup des gens de la sphère
sceptiques qui s'intéresse depuis ce de
près à la pratique
toi tu es plus dans la théorie en fait
du mal de m bouyer dans un sujet en
particulier même par rapport à un oui je
sais pas tu parles - je pense dessus de
fressies que d'autres jambes mais je
pense là moi je trouve ça ça vient ça
une victoire véganisme tracy dans
l'ensemble je trouve que tu es quand
même pas dans cette sphère sceptiques
tjoyas mains de ceux qu'elle le plus de
recul mais après c'est aussi ton propre
avantage je pense donc boutin du rgs
mais du coup peut-être que tu peux pas
te mouiller sur certains trucs mais
peut-être que c'est ça qui fait que tu
as à cette image me plaît plus
moralisateur ou pas forcément
moralisateur mais ouais idéaliste et le
côté il faudrait ça
mais en même temps tu peux pas vraiment
mouillé dans les pma et participez
vraiment complètement je pense que des
fois la chaîne d'actu participe pas
autant que tu voudrais au oui oui en
fait je pense que je participe pas au
même débat c'est ça le truc c'est que
oui je pense que j'ai perdu beaucoup de
sujets polémiques en fait est
typiquement je critique cette
scientifique et un livre bientôt à venir
sur les intelligences artificielles ou
c'est très très critique de beaucoup de
choses et il ya beaucoup d'idées ultras
contre intuitif dans le livre des trucs
quand j'ai écrit je vais faire je veux
faire défoncer donc c'est pas tant que
j'évite les sujets polémiques c'est
juste que c'est pas les mêmes sujets que
de foot sur qui tu peux pas par un débat
avec ces gens là donc je fais des débats
du coup c'est peut-être là bas je
propose de débattre sur le problème
éventuel dégagé ouais c'est vraiment une
bonne idée et a passé un petit peu dans
les cartons mais j'hésite encore amélie
alors il ya plusieurs aspects ça c'est
une question intéressante y en as well
as de la première fois c'est que fait
beaucoup déçu enfin moyenne point il ya
des sujets qui sont à prioriser par
rapport à d'autres et du coup je prie je
pense qu'à des sujets dont il faudra
davantage parler parce que je pense
changement climatique ou vision c'est un
truc qui me terrifie
et c'est vraiment de ça dont j'ai envie
de parler donc passé du temps à parler
d'autre chose
c'est c'est utiliser l'attention de
l'attention des gens pour de mauvaises
raisons
il ya donc ça c'est une des raisons
l'autre raison c'est que
j'ai pris de l'âge
c'est pas facile aussi de se donner
cette confrontés à des avis divers les
différents des nôtres c'est jamais
facile et le faire publiquement c'est
vraiment pas facile bref je sais pas mme
à la question aussi mais c'est une idée
intéressante oui non mais c'était
c'était juste pour rire ccc c'était
clairement un dilemme que lui en ce
moment tmx n'a peut-être qu être un peu
moralisateur c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose
je sais que tu avais été dégoûté par par
des vegan hyper moraliste tu ton
dégoûtés de cette réflexion là dans un
premier temps mais je crois que tu es
très loin de voir leur attitude est
peut-être que tu ne devrais pas avoir
peur ne paraîtra un tout petit peu
moralisateur de temps en temps quel geek
je pensais que mon problème n'est pas un
problème c'est en fait l'impression que
j'ai c'est que le hashtag des baptêmes
de hashtag débat tant mieux on a
l'impression que en fait on sait pas
vraiment si ça marche pour l'instant
l'impression que c'est un truc il faut
tout le monde le fasse pour voir les
effets et on a l'impression que tu
essaie d'appliquer ajoute avec des
bâtons mieux manger tellement hashtag
des bâtons mieux mais tu essaie
d'appliquer hashtag n'est pas tombé à
des problèmes qui sont hyper urgent et
du coup on a l'impression qu'il faut se
dire bah ils sont tellement les gens
peut pas se permettre de tester une
nouvelle chose dont on n'est pas sûr que
ça marche on a déjà des méthodes de
débats et étant donné que c'est
tellement urgent il faut rester là
dessus on n'a pas tant
testez de cette nouvelle chose alors
typiquement en médecine l'homéopathie ça
tue des gens n'a pas le temps de se
mettre à faire du hashtag des bâtons
mais avec ces gens là il faut tout de
suite les arrêter faut pas se permettre
de tester une nouvelle chose à chaque
débat tombe c'est un peu l'impression de
jeu qu'est ce que je devrais faire pas
de solutions vidéo qui montre les
limites des bâtons ça peut être une
réponse intelligente sans aller à la
confrontation
essayez d'y réfléchir sur place timide
et aussi de réfléchir aux critiques qui
lui sont adressées pour les comprendre
en chercher les fondements et pas
forcément il donne une réponse mais du
moins montré que que tuer ta comprise je
pense que ça peut être une réponse de
manière moins frontal intelligente par
rapport à ce problème la vue se montrer
que batak ont été entendus et
irréfléchie c'est un petit peu le plus
possible d'être intéressante vidéo sur
des bateaux lieu de les présenter passe
sous forme de vidéo ou une toiture par
les autres mais se forme d'un débat où
vous parler ensemble avec des invités
qui étaient contre toi avant et qui ont
accepté ou des choses comme ça et là on
serait peut-être encore plus dans le
sujet du débat tant mieux
avec les internautes donc c'était un peu
l'idée est en gros l'idée ce serait de
faire dans des épisodes probablement mon
podcast
puisque le temps de poser comme ce soit
si les idées après aussi des gens que
j'ai envie d'interviewer pour le coup de
casque
enfin je suis j'y connais rien mais j'ai
pas de communication non violente et ses
différentes façons débat est ce que ce
serait pas intéressant
j'espère que tu fais pas déjà sur la
chaîne s'est plongée normalement mais
est ce que serait pas intéressant
d'organiser je pars à deux ou à trois
aujourd'hui on va tester de débattre de
telles choses de cette façon là on va
tester ce débat là et puis écrit avec je
pense pas que les mêmes invités ou
d'autres la semaine d'après et on
reprend un autre débat est là on va
tester ce coup ci la méthode je sais pas
quoi et en fait on pourrait voir aussi
les limites les trucs obtient finalement
le
le problème de ce truc là c'est que tu
vois l'autre des tombées dans et en fait
on teste en fait comme des petits tests
les douaniers rippert humble en disant
on va tester en fait c'est pas tu vas
pas oui je vais vous montrer le modèle
mais un truc où j'imagine que doit y
avoir plein de formes de débat possible
d sur le cas des gens ont réfléchi et c
soit c'est une même thématique et on
peut faire passer mais j'en sais rien
enfin moi je trouverais intéressant de
voir ce qui reste maintenant on peut
déborder un peu ou de deux mineurs ou
deux nous servent aussi à un autre truc
mais qu'on passe plus de temps dessus
mais en fait on va faire une minute un
peu plus c'est moi j'aimerais que le
truc soit repris par d'autres
ça me fait chier que des bateaux mieux
soit associé à moi beaucoup de gens qui
associe à des bâtons à mieux et ça me
fait chier quand ça faisait j'aimerais
que tout le monde en parle et ça vient
pas d'une personne que comment je fais
mais pourquoi ne pas jumeler le hashtag
et bâtons mieux avec un hashtag
équivalent anglophone créer pourquoi pas
par judy ghallef ouais faut qu'elles
répondent un peu mes emails mais ouais
il est peut penser effectivement on voit
pas tant de gens bien des angles de bons
débats étaient organisés des débats
effectivement à contre voir des débats
qui se passe bien c'est que ça peut
aider en fait la faire comprendre c'est
parce que j'ai les yeux sur sur ses
impôts si l'idée de probablement axiome
aussi on peut mais plus probablement
essayer d'avoir des discussions qui sont
les réflexions politiques qui sont
d'accord mais en fait souvent un débat
d'un entretien fils technique je sais
qu'il ya une reprise que tu connais
parce qu'il n'est pas une association
qui s'appelle khiasma bon ben ça a l'air
et 20 en fait c'est un peut-être que
risky connaître sa copine s'appelle
albert moukheiber qu'un euro
scientifique e psychologue c'était
presque écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
votre cerveau vous jouer des tours est
en fait un classement ils prennent un
petit mois ça m'intéressera vachement
voir une vidéo sur ce qui fait par
exemple ils prennent un thème ''la
typiquement ici vingtaine
pas n'importe lequel est en fait le but
c'était parce que j'ai compris c'est
donc de débattre mais c'est pas deux il
amène les gens à comprendre à la fin
pourquoi est-ce que je pense si je pense
pas avec une méthode y faire préciser je
sais qu'il va dans des collèges en est
ci-dessous comme ça avec des supers
résultats ou les gamins ils en viennent
parfois changer d'avis parfois l'air et
ça s'appelle khiasma voilà je le sais je
sais pas ce que c'est je me dis ce que
tu vois pas faire une vidéo de suez pour
exemple j'adore moi je regarde aucun
débat politique la politique ça me
saoule pas ce que je vois trop de
l'écurie d'ego et tout ça me
désintéresse totalement et en fait
j'aimerais savoir ce que ça donnerait un
débat sans attaque par exemple où la
règle ce serait personnes on n'a pas le
droit de s'attaquer n'a pas le droit de
dire mais vous monsieur machin vous avez
je suis pas trop méchant avec mes
interviews et moi c'est pratique
politique c'est toujours plus dur c'est
inventé que la tonte en hasek se
répandent dans un truc tout con c'est tu
regarde quels sont les mieux et eu des
affiches comme ça un peu ils sentent un
peu une émulation un coach c'est de
faire ça mais ça qu'il ne fait pas assez
migrateurs un peu réceptifs quand même
avec des bâtons mieux de faire des films
dans tes vidéos de danse des bâtons pour
associer leurs visages à des bâtons
mieux s'ils savent que leur visage sur
les neiges et des cintres manière ils
savent que leur visage et associe des
bâtons mieux pas probablement des bâtons
mieux du coup peut-être qu'ils vont a
tendance à en parler ça c'est une super
expérience qu'elle a commencé avec
christophe ou peut-être mode
je suis d'accord que les cas pratique je
pense que c'est vraiment ce qui parle
aux gens et puis ce qui est bien aussi
c'est d'en percer une autocritique après
parce que je pense que c'est la façon de
la plus humble de répondre aux critiques
parce que par exemple
voilà c'est l'autre le seul aux
vidéastes qui parle de débat sur youtube
dans mon fils d'actualités de youtube
c'est fabien olicard parce qu'il ya eu
débat enfin l'applaudir et de l'analyse
et des bas avec une troupe de mentalist
et c'est intéressant parce que c'est
grand public en fait les gens il j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu le seul
accès qu'ils ont ouvert comme en débat
c'est fabien de cartes et c'est un
problème donc la fin c'est parce que
c'est un peu plus ludiques comme ça être
plus interactif on voit que il l'analyse
des l'argument bon après il analyse avec
les postures et ça mais ça peut être
intéressant de montrer un cas un cas
pratique et ensuite d'en faire la
critique ou l'analyse c'est peut-être un
petit peu plus ou moins moralisateur ou
quand on doit tracas chose à rajouter
vous peut en finir là qui fait ça sur sa
chaîne il prend de certains débats il
est très dangereux le thème politique du
coup pareil l'analyse margut membres
assurés mode mentaliste mais moi je veux
vraiment baraquements dati du coup ne la
laissent que aventure quelqu un qu est
ce que quelqu'un a une idée de génie
pourront continuer à faire en sorte que
d'autres gens prennent aussi au casting
cyprien this cuisine est ce que tu es là
si ce rythme je regarde sur les atomes
[Musique]
yugo décrypte on doit décréter par nom
par exemple des jeunes qui étaient
végétariens vega contre les châtiments
il a fait des tableaux
ils sont les dames on au quai max et
synthétique après je pense ce qu'on peut
avec le montage qui est qu'ils arrivent
à supprimer la moitié des dommages
collatéraux du débat il ya trois ans on
a super ça fait pas mal de bonnes idées
et je vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
parce que
[Applaudissements]
que vous aurez trouvé ce débat sur
achetés avec des bâtons mieux
intéressant et je vous invite notamment
à essayer de me faire des retours qui va
même revoir la vidéo en y réfléchissant
particulièrement à la qualité du débat
qu'on a eue sur hashtag des bâtons mieux
et en particulier qu'est ce que qu'est
ce qui aurait pu être mieux dans ce
débat en particulier qu'est ce que
j'aurais pu faire mieux dans ce débat en
tant que modérateur du débat
qu'est-ce que j'ai mal fait et qu'est ce
que je pourrais faire pour amener vers
une meilleure qualité de réflexion
collective ça m'intéresserait beaucoup
d'avoir vos retours à ce sujet en tout
cas ce que j'avais regardé si vous vous
intéressez au moins un peu à chaque
bateau mieux et ça me fait super plaisir
et ça me permet également de revenir sur
un aspect qui m'a frappé en revisionnant
et en montant la vidéo c'est que
finalement en fait on est quand même
beaucoup à parler de près ou de loin
2 comment au mieux débattre et du coup
ça me permet de me sentir beaucoup moins
seuls et demanderont que en fait il ya
quand même toute une communauté non
seulement de youtube heures mais
également de gens autour de soi hashtag
du bâton mieux et on n'est pas seuls et
c'est une bonne chose et maintenant on
va petit à petit j'espère mettre en
valeur de plus en plus ses autres
personnes qui réfléchissent également à
comment mieux débattre